let me start with nietzsche
he said without music life would be a
mistake
what do you think he means by that
let's talk some philosophy let's try to
analyze friedrich nature from a century
ago
it seems like
music has the ability to bring us so
much
uh
depth in our soul that's hard to access
any other way
and without it there would be a loss
beyond beyond the pleasure of it um
feels like it's a window into something
else
something that
no other medium can express quite the
same way
i would say not as automatically
something about music can do it
automatically
maybe
poetry or maybe
certain abstract uh forms can
get us there
but there's something
about music that really can get us there
quickly
but it's also the time to place the
history there's something about
like a lot of my family's still in
philly there's something about driving
through jersey
and listening to bruce springsteen
and they just i'll get like emotional
like listening to like i'm on fire
that like
one one of my favorite bruce springsteen
songs there's a there's a there's a
haunting kind of strumming to it it's
not a strumming
it's it's actually picked has a country
feel to almost like a johnny cash feel
actually and it
i don't know it makes me feel so for
people who don't know i'm on fire that
song
is
i guess
a love song to a woman
that
you can't
have because she's married or she's with
somebody else which i guess is quite a
lot of love songs but there's something
about the haunting nature of the guitar
and then it has to be driving through
jersey and i feel like
everyone has fallen in love with the
jersey girl at one point in their life
i don't know if that's true fair for her
but i i feel like that i haven't either
but i just feel like that i feel there's
something about bruce springsteen's like
yeah i've been there
i you know um
and that just takes you to a place of
emotion that you just
that captures love that captures longing
that captures the the heartbreak of just
the way time flows in life and in fact
it's finite and just all of that in a
single
single simple song the guy what else can
capture that
yeah i don't know um but but it's true
that uh there's a connection both
between time and place and music and
i
certain music growing up on the east
coast
didn't really resonate with me until i
spent time on the west coast eagles
being an example when i lived in new
york the eagles didn't really speak to
me zz top didn't really speak to me
and then when i started spending time in
california and driving through laurel
canyon
all of a sudden the music of the eagles
felt
appropriate somehow and i started
listening to it more
got it so not until you went out west
can you understand the sounds of the
west
so it's really like new york has a sound
what other places have a sound in the
united states i think every place does
and that said
sometimes we can get an experience
through music
of a place like we can resonate with the
music and not understand why
and then maybe when we go to the place
where it was created
it's almost like we have a knowingness
of that place it's not a strange place
anymore
yeah stevie ray vaughan with blues and
tech texas blues
you just listen to texas flood and just
again there's this like a woman you're
missing a broken heart and somehow that
connects to
to the place the eagles
what song the eagles connects with you
are we talking about like
uh
take it easy or are we talking more like
hotel california i'm thinking take it
easy but but both are great
yeah there's certain songs when i
started learning guitar when i was young
that's like i would like to be the kind
of person that not only knows how to
play this song but understands the song
and like
have that song be something i played 20
years ago
and i've lived with that song for a
while like hotel california is an
example
obviously there's the solo
but there's also the soulfulness of the
lyrics which i still don't understand
and it could be about anything and as
you get older i feel like the meaning of
the song could be anything yeah i think
that's true i think that's the beauty of
them i think when the person wrote them
they may have had one
interpretation
but it's not contingent on us getting
that interpretation to
like it or resonate with it or
feel it
in some ways the best
uh the best art is open enough
where
the artist gets to have their experience
when they make it and then the audience
gets to have their experience when they
listen and they don't have to be the
same
and then it connects thousands or
millions of people together
there's there's a togetherness of music
when you share that music when you're
listening to stuff together like in a
car first of all the car is a sacred
place so i work in part on autonomous
vehicles
and you start to think what are the
things you lose
when the car
stops being the central part of american
life
um
the car ownership it just feels like the
car when you're alone
it's like a therapist thing
session because you get angry
at all the other humans you get to and
then you get to
like sit in your own anger and emotion
you get to listen to the song on a long
road trip and
and
remember like run through your memories
the heartbreak
uh i don't know the one that got away
but also like
the beautiful moments all of it
yeah
and all that in the car
yeah driving also serves another purpose
and it's a
it's one of the things that we can do
that
we have to pay attention
enough not to crash
but typically can
essentially run on autopilot enough
where we could be thinking about
something else or
concentrating on something else and the
difference between concentrating on
something or trying to solve a problem
when you're solely trying to solve a
problem versus when you have some little
task that's keeping you occupied
i find
if i have some slider
something slight
to take care of
it frees
a more creative side of my mind to
better solve problems
you know i'm kind of jealous of people
that found that in painting for example
they'll be drawing or painting and
listening to so that that's the small
task you do
you're coloring in the lines
it's like this gentle peaceful
slow process
that requires just a small fraction of
your mind and then you can listen some
people listen to podcasts that way some
people listen to music that way
yeah
how do you do it how do you free your
mind
running is one of them
uh
there's a process
so the most
freeing of the mind for me has to go
through a process of a bit of pain for a
bit
so doing something difficult
uh it's just like a
airplane taking off or something so
like for example running the first few
miles would just be just
just first of all
the physical aspect which is like uh
you're so fat you're out of shape you're
this is this is getting old this that
okay that slowly dissipates and then the
demons come in who are like
you should be
you should be getting this and that and
this done you haven't gotten it done
you're like breaking promises all those
kinds of voices coming in and after that
maybe mile four it's like [ __ ] it
you just
you just run run with the wind at a very
slow pace but with the wind and then
and then you could think so it's the the
footsteps the physical activity but then
you could deeply think about stuff ideas
sort of design whether it's programming
design stuff or
like high level life decisions all those
kinds of things i would say
uh running i used to build bridges from
toothpicks
i used to be
a thing it's an engineering i guess some
people like
glue together airplanes and stuff like
that
but the bridge is
such
deeply honest work because at the end of
it you're gonna have to test that bridge
and you're gonna see
how good your work was the little
details but also the big picture do you
use glue or no
yeah you use glue
so it's not pure physics it's it's it's
uh materials engineering too
because uh the way
you want to do it is you actually split
the wood as thin as possible and then
glue it back together because the glue
is really
uh strong except for the arches and
things like that so you're building arch
bridges which is a whole other skill
because you have to bend the wood and
it's so cool because the thing can hold
thousands of times its weight
and then you get to watch it explode
at a certain point
from the pressure and when you do a
really good job it doesn't explode in a
kind of
some weak point that you didn't
anticipate just kind of starts cracking
it everything cracks everything explodes
it's just
pieces fly everywhere
and it's literally hundreds of hours of
work just explode
in front of you
and that's uh it's a metaphor for life
maybe
and it's all for nothing
except for the journey that you took to
get there
and
no one understands
you